hallo ihr lieben heute zeigen wir euch
wie man auf deutsch getränke bestellt
jetzt geht schon los
[Musik]
wie bestellen sie leitungswasser auf
deutsch einmal leitungswasser bitte ich
hätte gern ein glas leitungswasser kann
ich bitte ein leitungswasser bekommen
wie würdest du einen leitungswasser
bestellen könnte wird
ich hätte gerne ein glas leitungswasser
und wie bestellt sie ein stilles wasser
ein schönes wasser bitte ich hätte gerne
ein stilles wasser bitte und wie will
sie ein wasser mit kohlensäure umstellen
ich möchte gern ein glas mineralwasser
mit kohlensäure
ich hätte gern ein mineralwasser mit
kohlensäure heftigen sprudelwasser bitte
ein sprudelwasser bitte bitte ein wasser
mit gas oder einen sprudel halt einfach
ein wasser mit leben etwas damit leben
ich hätte gerne ein mineralwasser ich
hätte gern ein wasser mit kohlensäure
bitter wie würden sie einem raum sind
software stellen ich möchte einen
orangensaft keine römischen würstchen
ich nehme bitte einen orangensaft eine
rasche saft bitte ich würde sagen einen
orangensaft bitte ich hätte gerne einen
orangensaft
wie würden sie eine cola bestellen eine
cola bitte eine kalte cola bitte ich
hätte gerne eine cola
ich krieg eine cola bitte ich hätte
gerne bitte eine cola
die will sie eine abwahl bis 1
ich hätte gerne eine apfelschorle wenn's
geht naturtrüb keine apfelschorle bitte
eine apfelschorle bitte eine
apfelschorle bitte ich würde gerne eine
apfelschorle haben
wie würdest du einen kaffee bestellen
ein kaffee bitte bitte eine tasse kaffee
ein latte macchiato bitte ich hätte
gerne einen kaffee
[Musik]
wie wählen sie einen radler bestellen
ich hätte gern ein radler bitte ich
hätte gern ein radler in bayern wo ich
herkomme
dann wird oft die frage gestellt was
bekommt sie ihr und dann ist
dementsprechend die antwort ich bekomme
ein radler
wenn aber normal was trinken sie oder
was trinkst du dann sage ich ich hätte
gerne einen radler bitte ich würde gerne
ein radler haben und das letzte wie
würden sie ein bier bestellen ein bier
für mich bitte ein bier und ein
alkoholfreies bier
ich nehme ein alkoholfreies bier bitte
ein alkoholfreies bier bitte ich hätte
gern ein alkoholfreies bier für mich ein
alkoholfreies bier bitte und jetzt seid
ihr dran probiert auf jeden fall unsere
apps ittling aus aßling könnt ihr
nämlich einen vokabeltrainer finden
interaktive übungen und viele kleine
geschichten um euer deutsch zu
verbessern
[Musik]
und jetzt sage ich nur noch dank fürs
zuschauen und bis nächste woche
[Musik]
[Applaus]